je suis ici à dire maintenant
j'ai envie de défendre ce territoire
aussi parce que je laime de faim de tout
mon être je crois que je pourrais pas
vivre ailleurs en fait j'ai envie aussi
que ce territoire je suis ambitieuse
ambitieuse pour ce territoire voilà je
n'ai pas envie quand le conte le garde
dans cette congard de ce single images
du d'un petit coin comme ça où les gens
vivent de manière archaïque et sans
culture non c'est pas c'est pas l'image
que je veux pour pour le sundgau parce
que les gens d'ici sont différents les
gens d'ici ont des savoirs faires les
gens liste d'ici ont une histoire
plein de qualités et peuvent les montrer
au monde aussi et je crois qu'il faut le
montrer j'ai envie de les accompagner
dans ce dans tout ça mes priorités pour
ce territoire c'est de donner envie aux
gens de venir y vivre actuellement dans
le dans les os meego nous avons des
problèmes de lier aux
au commerce qui disparaissent
démographie aussi qui est en chute libre
à ce qui pose des problèmes notamment au
niveau des écoles aussi par exemple
donc ce que j'ai envie de faire vraiment
c'est de m'investir pour vous mettre
pour proposer en fait aux habitants
d'ici une scolarité de qualité en par
exemple en accompagnant les communes qui
souhaitent se regrouper pour construire
ensemble un lieu commun d'enseignements
avec une autre périscolaire une prise en
charge des élèves à midi pour la cantine
parce que c'est ce que les gens
attendent
c'est ce que les jeunes familles à temps
je crains fait que si on ne travaille
pas dans ce sens ça le laussou go
pourrait rapidement perdre de ses
habitants les lotissements pourrait les
parcelles ne pourrait pas être vendus je
crois que les élus ne sont pas encore
assez conscients de l'impact de du
scolaire sur sur la vie de leur commune
en général ce qui a été fait dans le
cadre du travail de mémoire qui a été
engagée à durmenach a créé en fait une
grande solidarité entre les personnes
on a en s'est rendu compte que les
quinze personnes qui étaient engagés au
début dans ce projet sont devenus 58
cents personnes à travailler autour
d'une restauration d'une maison à venir
ici débroussailler un cimetière ensuite
à retaper des bancs dans la forêt à
faire à s'engager dans le cadre de la
journée citoyenne où on était plus de
100 personnes
je pense que les gens doivent
réapprendre à vivre ensemble à faire des
choses ensemble est actuellement jeudi
la situation financière des communes du
département de la france est tellement
difficile
on ne va plus pouvoir compter sur
l'argent pour faire des belles choses
mais je crois que je crois qu'il faut
compter sur les gens compter sur l'homme
sur l'humain ici à durmenach on a pu le
faire j'ai eu la chance de vivre ça avec
les habitants de ma commune j'aimerais
que que ça puisse se faire ailleurs
aussi dans ce canton j'ai été